this is also from the daily wire it says
a fort lauderdale florida police chief
was fired after an investigation stated
that he had asked which one is blacker
when considering a promotion and also
allegedly pointed to photographs on a
conference room of the department's
command staff saying that wall is too
white and i'm gonna change that
former uh fort lauderdale police chief
larry siroto 48 the first openly gay
police chief hired in fort lauderdale
was fired last thursday after bias
complaints filed last october with the
equal with the u.s equal employment
opportunity commission prompted
that that prompted an investigation two
police officers said they had been
denied promotions based on race sexual
orientation and gender city manager
chris
inform
lagerbloom
police department he would freeze all
promotions until further notice to
address concerns surrounding the recent
police department promotions
that's a really interesting story
because you don't often hear about
people in these positions getting fired
for anti-white bias i mean it almost
never happens
and you could point out that what what
this police chief was saying
that we need to be blacker that well
that's too white too many white
candidates that's that's like the
official policy
in many states in many of these
institutions including academic
including academia that's what
affirmative action is
and it's also discriminatory and racist
but he came out and said and
some employees actually had the the
courage i think the real courage here
given the backlash that they could have
experienced
had the courage to go
to
not accept that
and they went to the equal rights
commission and reported this
because this is racial bias
and this is exactly what needs to happen
you know i've made this exact point
about employees at these woke companies
who are forced to sit for
crt training where they're singled out
by race and told that if you're white
here are all the bad things about you
and here's what you need to say if
you're white here's what you need to
think and believe
and you know even in some cases having
these uh indoctrination sessions the
brainwashing sessions where only white
people are required to attend i mean
that sort of thing
that is
blatant discrimination your the law
actually forbids that
okay now i'm sure the left democrats
they they would like to change the law
to explicitly allow for
um
anti-white racism in these contexts
but as of right now they haven't done it
so we do we do have equal rights laws
which if you if you read the way the
laws are written
it says that you're not allowed to
single anybody out for harassment
negative treatment or anything like that
based on their race and the way the law
is written it doesn't say as long as
they're black it just says based on race
the companies get away with it because
they're really hardly ever sued for it
these things are not
reported and the employees just kind of
sit there and endure it
and maybe they'll take
pictures and they'll put it on twitter
and it'll go viral and people complain
about it and that's fine like what
happened with uh what was it coca-cola i
mean there's been a bunch of companies
and sure go ahead and do that but then
sue them
for rate for illegal racial
discrimination against you as a white
employee
so that's real racism let's go to some
fake racism i just wanted to mention
this serena williams is
a wildly successful and famous athlete
she's got she's she's worth i'm sure
hundreds of millions of dollars they
just made a movie about her um she's
just
celebrated and loved and everything
but she is still a victim so the new
york times did a story about serena
williams and in the print version
apparently there still is a print
version so that's the real
headline news to me in the print version
they apparently put put a picture with
the story that was not serena williams
it was her i think her her sister it was
the wrong picture
and these kinds of mistakes happen right
um
and but serena williams
was not willing to just say oh okay well
mistakes happen who cares
i mean everyone knows who i am i don't
have to worry that i'm being erased here
people are gonna forget what i look like
she couldn't do that so instead she
sends out a tweet no matter how far we
come we get reminded that it's not
enough this is why i raised 111 million
dollars for serena ventures to support
the founders who are overlooked by
ingrained systems woefully unaware of
their biases
because even i am overlooked you could
do better yes even serena williams is
overlooked
serena williams who
they did the article about her
okay serena you the article was about
you you're overlooked in an article
about you
one of the hundreds of articles that
have been written about you through your
career
i'm being overlooked i'm a victim of
racism
this is this is what the um racial
indoctrination on the left gets you it's
just
you end up with people who are totally
unwilling to just look looking for every
possible slight
and totally unwilling to extend any
grace whatsoever
always assuming the worst possible
motivations
okay in the world of the race hustler
um there are no innocent mistakes there
are no oversights
there's
nothing inconvenient can happen to you
that is not
grounded in racism
so serena williams another um another
victim we should all apologize to her
for this horrible life that we forced
her to live as a multi-millionaire
athlete hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated